so far you've used the api's Explorer to
investigate and test the functions in
your applications we've got the get
profile the save profile however the
conference central application includes
a full web UI and each of the pages in
the web UI sends calls to the endpoints
API on the back end as you implement the
back end functionality the web pages in
the app will start to work right now
they don't all work for example if you
go to show conferences it's not going to
find any conferences because the
implementation because you haven't
written the code to find conferences but
in this lesson we implemented the code
to get and set profiles so the my
profile page now works so let's see what
happens if I change my profile let me
change my t-shirt size to very small
extra small change my display name to
Jocelyn be update my profile and the
profile has been updated excellent when
I click the update profile button what
happens is that this web page in behind
the scenes is sending a call after the
save profile endpoint function that you
just implemented the goal of this course
is to help you learn how to develop App
Engine applications not to teach you
JavaScript however I do want to point
out the code that makes a call to get
profile and to save profile so now here
we are in Eclipse and you'll find the
code for the web pages or the web UI
under SRC web app and you'll see there's
the CSS folder the fonts folder the IMG
there's index dot HTML then there's a
java script folder j/s and then there's
this thing called partials which is the
HTML pages what I want to look at first
is controllers jas because this has the
code that calls to get profile and the
save profile methods so let's look at
get profile so here's the code that
sends the call to the get profile
endpoint function and you see here it's
gap e dot client to invoke the client
library and then
conference the name of the API and then
get profile is a method name and again
we execute and then here's the code to
call when the requests are successfully
executed and in this case you can see
that the codes just right here in line
is not in a separate function but this
is the callback to call when the call to
get profile succeeds let's look at save
profile I'll search for it here it is
and again I just want to point out
here's the call to gap e dot client orgy
api doc client and then the conference
is the name of the endpoints and then
save profile is a method to call in this
case we're passing it one argument and
then we call the execute to execute the
request and again here's the call here's
the code to execute in the callback
that's called when save profile
completes successfully if save profile
completes successfully so that's what I
really wanted to point out here I'm not
going to go into the rest of the UI code
in detail I just wanted to show you the
hook where the JavaScript issues the
call to the endpoint functions as you go
through the course you're going to be
implementing the endpoint functions and
I wanted you to know how they get called
from the UI